Au lieu de ça, elle éclaire le ciel
et se dirige vers l'univers
où elle ne nous est pas bénéfique.
Dans de telles photos de la Terre,
je vois une catastrophe environnementale.
Ce ne sont pas des bijoux,
mais des tumeurs.
Je suis astronome.
Ce ne sera une surprise pour personne
que j'aie toujours aimé le ciel nocturne.
Je suis un cliché ambulant.
Mais quand je grandissais dans le Minnesota,
une de mes activités favorites les nuits d'été
était de prendre mon vieux sac de couchage
et d'aller me coucher dans le champ derrière la maison,
et d'y passer des heures à admirer le ciel nocturne.
Pourtant, ça requérait une bonne dose de courage pour affronter l'obscurité,
et les nuages de moustiques.
Et mon sac de couchage ne sentait pas vraiment bon non plus.
(Rires)
Mais il y avait une étoile précise
Je jouais à ce jeu
d'essayer de me concentrer sur cette étoile intensément,
jusqu'à ce que tout le reste disparaisse de mon vue
et que cette seule étoile soit tout ce que je pouvais voir.
Je ne pouvais que garder cette concentration
que quelques instants fugaces.
Mais quand j'y parvenais,
je ressentais une connexion profonde avec l'univers.
Presque une sensation de vertige,
comme si j'allais tomber dans l'espace.
Et quand cela arrivait -
je sais que cela semble ridicule -
je me sentais à la fois infiniment insignifiante
et aussi étrangement importante.
Cette étoile que j'admirais nuit après nuit s'appelle Vega.
Vega, c'est l'étoile la plus brillante de la constellation de la Lyre,
le nom d'un de mes chiens aussi, et ce n'est pas un hasard.
(Rires)
Mais cette expérience se perd.
Ma constellation préférée, la Lyre,
de Manhattan, on la voit ainsi.
Les gens qui vivent dans un environnement urbain et suburbain,
quand ils sortent la nuit et lèvent les yeux au ciel,
ils ne peuvent pas être émerveillés par la majesté de l'univers
car ils ne voient presque rien.
Ce ciel nocturne banal et complètement vide,
est dû à toute la lumière que nous produisons la nuit.
Ces mêmes lumières que nous observons de l'espace
brillent vers l'atmosphère,
où elles se réfléchissent pour former un smog lumineux sans relief.
Ce smog lumineux sans relief a un nom :
la pollution lumineuse.
En tant qu'astronome,
je peux déterminer la gravité de la pollution lumineuse
en observant la luminosité des étoiles dans le ciel.
Et il s'avère que,
quand vous essayez de comprendre les secrets du cosmos,
c'est vraiment utile de pouvoir l'observer.
Et --
(Rires)
C'est vrai.
Or la lumière que nous essayons de détecter
provient de millions ou de milliards d'années-lumière,
par conséquent, elle est presque imperceptible.
Comme l'astronomie est mon métier,
je me bats avec ça tous les jours pour faire mon travail.
Je peux vous dire que c'est un gros problème.
Mais le problème dépasse amplement
le fait de perdre notre capacité poétique d'observer les étoiles.
Par exemple,
des plantes et des espèces d'animaux innombrables en sont affectées.
Nous pourrions évoquer les tortues marines,
les pollinisateurs
ou quelques-unes de ces espèces super importantes.
Elles sont si mignonnes.
Mais je préfère évoquer
le bulot, un être tranquille et sans prétention.
Vous en avez peut-être déjà vu
sans leur accorder vraiment beaucoup de réflexion.
Mais ils sont très cool.
En une année,
un bulot va rarement bouger plus que 10 mètres.
Cela signifie que quand ils attaquent leurs proies,
ils peuvent atteindre la vitesse phénoménale d'un millimètre par heure.
Et --
(Rires)
c'est suffisant
parce qu'ils attaquent des choses comme les balanes.
(Rires)
Les bulots colonisent les zones côtières intertidales
où il s'avère
qu'ils jouent un rôle central dans l'écosystème.
Non seulement le bulot est un des prédateurs invertébrés les plus dominants,
mais d'autres prédateurs, comme les crabes et les oiseaux le trouvent à leur goût.
Ces malheureux escargots sont donc dans une situation précaire
parce que s'ils descendent trop bas dans l'eau
les crabes les menacent,
mais s'ils s'éloignent trop de l'eau,
les oiseaux vont s'en régaler.
Pourquoi une astronome vous parle-t-elle des bulots ?
Je me le demande aussi.
Parce que leur comportement est influencé par la pollution lumineuse.
Par exemple,
si les bulots sont soumis à la lumière artificielle la nuit,
ils sont deux fois plus susceptibles de rester sous l'eau avec leurs prédateurs.
Et cela les expose à un risque majeur.
Et ce n'est pas comme s'ils pouvaient s'échapper rapidement.
Et --
(Rires)
et l'autre problème, c'est qu'ils bougent littéralement
à la vitesse d'un escargot.
Quand une population est décimée,
elle peut prendre des décennies pour se reconstituer.
Et cela affecte le reste de son écosystème,
les autres espèces, comme les oiseaux, les balanes et les crabes.
On vient de glisser sur un petit exemple
pour expliciter l'effet de cascade que peut déclencher la pollution lumineuse
dans un écosystème entier.
Presque toutes les espèces étudiées à ce jour
sont affectées par la pollution lumineuse.
Cela inclut les humains.
Parlons un peu de nous.
Vous ne serez pas surpris d'apprendre
que la pollution lumineuse peut affecter notre capacité à bien dormir la nuit.
Mais vous pourriez être surpris d'entendre qu'elle est liée à l'obésité.
En fait, dans une étude récente,
on a constaté que la pollution lumineuse contribue à plus de 70 %
du taux d'obésité dans 80 pays.
C'est même pire :
en fait, la pollution lumineuse contribue autant à l'excès de poids
que la malbouffe.
Et ça peut encore empirer :
les personnes qui sont soumises la nuit
à des quantités significatives de lumière artificielle
ont 50 % de risque supplémentaire de développer un cancer du sein.
En fait, la pollution lumineuse est corrélée avec certains types de cancer
de manière généralisée.
Des expériences contrôlées en laboratoire démontre un lien direct
entre un accroissement de lumière artificielle la nuit
et le taux de croissance tumorale.
Vous vous demandez sans doute comment la lumière normale
peut bien influencer les taux de cancer.
Tout semble se résumer à une hormone super importante
appelée mélatonine,
qui a évolué dans notre organisme pendant des millions d'années
pour réguler notre rythme circadien.
La réaction de notre organisme quand la lumière touche la rétine,
à l'arrière de l'œil, la nuit,
est une perturbation de la production de mélatonine,
et l'interruption de celle-ci
affecte toute une chaîne d'autres processus chimiques,
et cela inclut la production d'œstrogènes.
Le déséquilibre chimique que nous provoquons
cause des choses vraiment mauvaises.
En fait, c'est si mauvais pour la santé
que le Centre international de recherche sur le cancer
a ajouté la perturbation du rythme circadien humain
dans sa liste des cancérogènes probables.
Et juste pour le fun, permettez-moi d'ajouter
que la pollution lumineuse a été liée,
au hasard, aux maux de tête, à l'anxiété, à la dépression, au diabète,
aux maladies cardiovasculaires, la liste est longue.
Votre santé peut ne pas vous préoccuper.
Après tous, on va tous mourir.
Autant mourir dans une pièce lumineuse.
(Rires)
Rire de la mort est assez étonnant.
Mais vous pourriez vous soucier de l'argent.
L'argent gaspillé dans cette lumière inutile,
et je veux dire la seule lumière qui part dans l'univers,
et ne nous fait aucun bien.
On parle de trois milliards de dollars par an.
C'est assez d'argent pour construire,
1 000 éoliennes de plus de 100 kw,
ou pour financer les écoles publiques de Washington pendant deux ans,
ou, mon exemple préféré, parce que j'en veux vraiment une
mais je ne peux pas me le permettre,
acheter 30 000 Tesla Model X.
(Rires)
Et cela inclut le crédit d'impôt pour un véhicule électrique.
Et puis il y a les coûts existentiels.
Je n'ai pas de données
sur comment notre perte de repère sur notre place dans le cosmos
nous affecte.
Mais je suis convaincue
que cela doit avoir un impact sur notre humanité
plus important que les autres statistiques que je viens d'évoquer.
Et ça empire avec le temps.
La quantité de pollution lumineuse double tous les 35 ans environ.
Cela signifie qu'au cours de la prochaine décennie,
pratiquement toute la moitié Est des États-Unis
sera constamment plus lumineuse que le crépuscule.
Il y a encore un autre problème avec la pollution lumineuse,
bien pire que ce que nous pouvons voir de nos propres yeux.
Nos yeux ont évolué pour détecter une petite plage
du spectre complet de la lumière.
Toute la lumière que nous ne pouvons pas voir,
la lumière invisible,
elle aussi a un problème de pollution.
C'est principalement dû à la technologie moderne,
les portables, les systèmes de signal radar des voitures
et il paraît que nous ayons besoin d'appareils qui communiquent entre eux.
Toute cette technologie moderne émet des signaux puissants
capables de submerger
cette lumière extrêmement faible que nous essayons de détecter,
venue du reste de l'univers,
et qui, rappelez-vous, concerne la plus grande partie de l'univers.
(Rires)
Il y a les satellites aussi.
Ils causent un problème sur les longueurs d'onde visibles et invisibles.
Beaucoup d'entreprises ont des projets de déploiement de milliers de satellites
en orbite terrestre.
Ils seront non seulement plus nombreux,
littéralement plus nombreux que les étoiles visibles dans le ciel,
mais ils vont aussi réfléchir la lumière invisible vers la Terre.
Donc pour les astronomes,
qui utilisent la lumière invisible pour étudier l'univers,
ça signifie observer le soleil
et essayer de discerner une bougie d'anniversaire derrière.
D'accord, je veux être claire,
il n'y a rien de fondamentalement mauvais dans les technologies modernes,
les téléphones portables, les satellites ou les radars des voitures.
Je ne suis pas certaine des appareils ménagers.
(Rires)
Je n'ai pas encore succombé
et acheté un four qui parle à mon téléphone portable.
J'allume la lumière la nuit, comme tout le monde.
Mais le message est celui-ci :
il y a des problèmes dans le monde,
comme nous en entendons parler aujourd'hui,
qui sont si accablants qu'ils semblent insolubles.
La pollution lumineuse visible ne fait pas partie de ces problèmes.
C'est même ridiculement simple.
Il y a cinq choses super simples que vous pouvez faire.
N'utilisez pas une lumière plus lumineuse que nécessaire.
N'utilisez pas de lumière quand ce n'est pas nécessaire.
Ces lumières que vous utilisez,
assurez-vous qu'elles sont dirigées vers le bas
et non vers le ciel.
Parlons un instant des LED.
Si vous avez le choix, n'achetez pas les bleues.
Recherchez des mots comme « blanc chaleureux ».
Si vous achetez des LED qualifiées de « lumière naturelle » ou « du jour »,
c'est comme dire que vous détestez l'espace.
(Rires)
Et enfin,
vous pourriez en devenir le porte-parole.
Dans votre communauté locale,
cherchez s'il y a un règlement d'éclairage
et s'il est possible de le rendre plus favorable au ciel nocturne.
Ou, oserais-je, vous pourriez même plaider au niveau fédéral
en demandant avec respect à nos représentants fédéraux,
certains sont peut-être être ici,
de ne pas galvauder notre vision de l'univers invisible
au plus offrant qui polluer à l'envi,
et c'est en fait ce qu'il se passe.
Maintenant, comme tout bon professeur,
je vais vous donner un devoir.
Si vous n'avez jamais vu un ciel nocturne vraiment sombre,
sortez la nuit et faites-en l'expérience.
Parce que si vous ne le faites pas,
vous ignorez ce que vous ratez
et dans la foulée, vous ignorez la perte que cela représente pour l'humanité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)